welcome back I am super excited today to
introduce you to the new second edition
of our book data-driven science and
engineering by myself and Nathan Kutz
This truly is a labor of love this is a
subject both Nathan and I are super
passionate about and we really put a lot
of ourselves into the second edition so
we're super happy with it and I hope you
get a ton of benefit out of the things
we added to this so I'm just going to
walk you through kind of what the
motivation for this book is what the
philosophy is and what's new in the
second edition so you can decide if this
is something you want to read yourself
and chances are very good I will put a
link in the description to a PDF of this
book so you can read it usually for free
let's uh you know stay tuned for that
down below
okay so um this is the second edition of
a book that Nathan and I wrote a number
of years ago so the first version of
this book I think came out in 2019 we
had been working on it for about four or
five years before that I'm a professor
in mechanical engineering with adjunct
appointments in applied math aerospace
engineering and computer science and
engineering Nathan Kutz is a professor
with dual appointments in applied math
and electrical engineering and the first
edition of our book data-driven science
and engineering was really very much
focused on
teaching emerging Technologies and
machine learning and data-driven methods
to Engineers okay so not just computer
scientists but real Engineers you know
aerospace engineers mechanical engineers
electrical engineers and so on and so
forth who had deep domain knowledge and
physics knowledge we wanted to give them
the tools in machine learning dynamical
systems and control theory that are kind
of driving the field forward and
similarly we wanted to give methods
people who are you know maybe in
computer science or applied math
developing these new techniques in in
data intensive methods we wanted to give
them you know some insight into how
their methods could be really applied in
physical systems and Engineering Systems
so kind of two big audiences trying to
tie it together here in this book
but the field changes so rapidly even in
the last three years things changed so
much we needed to to put out a second
edition and I'll tell you about what the
features are in a minute
so kind of the philosophy that I take in
this whole world of you know how do I
bring machine learning into engineering
is the following so behind these boxes
there's a bunch of cool fluid flows
that's one of my passions in engineering
is fluid modeling and flow control
because it's so applicable to nearly
every trillion dollar industry whether
it's defense Health Care Transportation
energy you name it you know modeling and
controlling fluids is going to help us
do that better and machine learning is
helping us model and control fluids
better it's helping with us with almost
all engineering tasks so at the end of
the day the philosophy I like to take
and we definitely take this in the book
is that there are some fundamental
engineering tasks regardless of what
your discipline is things like modeling
design optimization sensor placement
estimation and feedback control this is
just a small list of many of the
engineering tasks we have
and at the end of the day almost all of
these tasks end up being really hard
optimization problems they're hard
because the physics is non-linear and
multi-scale usually in space and time
which leads to high dimensional
non-convex optimization problems and so
one of the key ideas is that machine
learning is this process of building
models from data we have an increasing
wealth of data we have better
optimization algorithms and so we can
build models from data with optimization
that's what machine learning is and we
can start solving some of these
engineering tasks with these machine
learning models and with these emerging
machine learning optimization techniques
if you think about training a neural
network that's a high dimensional
non-convex optimization problem maybe we
can use those same techniques when we
try to learn good sensor placement or
some feedback control law for a
nonlinear problem so these Technologies
go really naturally together engineering
tasks are increasingly solvable with
machine learning models and data-driven
optimizations that's a perspective
and to send extent the reason this is
true is because
of data so even you know very complex
systems very high dimensional systems
whether it's you know a network of
neurons in your brain a disease ripping
across a continent or a very complex
geospatial fluid flow patterns exist in
your data you can compress that data you
can extract key features and you can use
those with these data intensive methods
for modeling estimation prediction and
control
and so our book starts off with how
extract these patterns from data and
then how do you use those patterns for
modeling for decision making for control
for things like that so we're very much
focused on this idea of how do you
extract low dimensional patterns and
features from high dimensional data and
then how do you use that in an
engineering context for dynamical
systems and control
okay good
we've added a ton this is a very major
overhaul on the second edition it's not
just that we went from Blue to Pink
we for example okay new to the second
edition we have new chapters two
entirely new chapters one on
reinforcement learning and one on
physics and for machine learning these
are two extremely exciting and rapidly
developing fields that we thought were
you know first off they fit the theme of
the book very very well they're at this
intersection of engineering and machine
learning and so these are two really
really exciting new chapters that we
have added
we have moved from having just Matlab
code in the first version now every
single code is in Matlab and python we
have python codes for every single
example in the entire book and if you go
I think in our on our website we also
have some codes in Julia R and C plus
plus
in various you know stages of deployment
but we have full code in Python and
Matlab
in my videos I notice the viewers want
python at least three to one so this was
a huge overhaul for us
every single section every section of
the book every chapter every section
there is a video either by myself or by
Nathan on one of our two YouTube
channels so if there is something you
are reading about and you're a little
confused go check it out on YouTube and
maybe it'll make more sense when we
explain it to you in person okay again
something we're passionate about is
making these things have lots of
different ways you can learn you can
read about them you can try to code them
up yourself you can hear us kind of give
you a more classic style lecture like
this on our light board
um we have new sections throughout the
entire book so in addition to these new
chapters most of the existing chapters
have new sections that dive deeper into
material we may have missed or
overlooked in the first chapter the
first edition so for example in our
chapter on Fourier analysis we added a
new section on the Laplace transform
super important for control theory and
Dynamics we overhauled the neural
network section you know entirely
because that field is moving so quickly
same with the data-driven dynamical
system so lots of new sections
throughout and we also have homework for
every single chapter so extensive
homework that was not there in the first
edition of the book now we have homework
for again every chapter of this ranging
from kind of easy to medium to research
level projects so you can use this for
classes if you want and really get some
inspiration for how not just to to
codify the material and to you know
learn by doing but also to really get
started on some research level
challenges and so some of the advanced
homeworks so you know these are the main
ones we found a bunch of typos Nathan
and I are far from perfect uh there were
a lot of typos in the first edition it's
much much cleaner in the second edition
so these are kind of some of the big
things we've changed and I hope you like
I hope you find you know these new
chapters to be really really useful I
hope you find the python code maybe many
of you you know were asking for this I
hope I hope this is really useful and
you can actually use these techniques
more
um you know because of this this this
code
uh and again this is a link
databook.pdf this is a link I think this
is currently a link to the first edition
of the book but we're going to update
this so you know hopefully by the time
you watch this this links to the second
edition
um PDF of the book so you can go check
this out for yourself
um you know if you like a paper copy
great buy it if you want to use this and
have a searchable version by all means
and please do
it's website databookuw.com where we you
know we have each chapter broken up into
the video so you can go to our YouTube
or you can come here to databookuw.com
it has links to all of the code all the
data sets all the different languages
all the videos this is a pretty useful
resource I find myself going here pretty
often
um Dynamics lab on GitHub this is our
kind of group GitHub repository between
my group and Nathan kutz's group and so
we have lots and lots of of repos here
you'll notice Data Book Python and data
book Matlab that is a living repository
of all of the codes for every chapter of
the book so if you want to figure out
how to make a robust PCA algorithm in
Python go here and go to chapter three
and download that code and it's there
for you without much you know much
searching
early this is my YouTube channel Nathan
has a great YouTube channel also where
you know all of the sections in the book
again are here this is me presumably
showing you the phase portrait for a
double well system but again that's this
is our light board setup where every
single video every single section really
is Illustrated
um you know hopefully in a way that
helps you understand the material
okay so
um that's the the mile high summary of
the new features in this book I'm so
excited
um you know we really really were
passionate about making this we loved
the first version we saw a lot of
potential to make the second version
even better and so I hope you like it
too let us know in the comments if
there's things you want in the Third
Edition if there's things that you know
we did in the second edition that you
really did like or you know maybe made
it harder for you or easier so so do let
us know all right thank you